you know the movie
they knew that story for a long time but
they couldn't do the 30-year rule 30
years later they could make the movie
and tell the story
i think we need some kind of a 20 year
old amazing idea who's implementing that
dude what i'm trying to say is why the
hell would you have your own
people now you've only got part of it
you only got part of the equation
now let me give you the other part this
company wants to sell stuff in china
big company corporation yeah you know
200 200 billion dollars a year
uh valuation they see
things happening in washington dc that
impacts their business in china what do
they do
they hire a pr firm they are a lobbying
firm they hire a law firm in washington
d.c
what do those guys do they begin to go
and talk to the government so who
lobbies in washington dc for the chinese
communist party
it's not not just about the think tank
guys who is lobbying in washington dc
for the chinese communist party the
biggest lobby who is
the u.s chamber of commerce the business
community of america
that's who money talks follow the money
is what you're saying follow the money
yeah so so i don't know you know this
makes me very uncomfortable
but at the same time it doesn't make me
that confident i've sat in the meetings
and listened and i've
i've actually questioned the
representatives like
who do you represent do you represent an
american corporation do you represent
the chinese communist party
that's your personal question this is
very engaging this is very basic
first of all you know guidelines on who
you can accept money from
period there has to be guidelines on who
you as an organization like u.s chamber
of commerce who you can accept money
from
i'm i'm i'm checking the u.s chamber of
commerce is responsive to their members
who are their members corporate america
what a corporate america say
don't screw with our business in china
don't do it
don't do it yeah nike just came out and
said we're a brand of china we love
china we're planned for china so that's
exactly what you're talking about that's
exactly what i'm so
people the problem is money over country
patrick
people do not understand how washington
dc works
you don't know how the washington dc
works that's the problem
people think this is why they call it
the swamp it is
exactly what they're called and it's not
because people hate the country
right these people are you brought up
mcconnell
and uh in biden they are convinced that
the best thing for the country
is to have this relationship with china
they
and and and why why are they convinced
of themselves because they're
because they would be close no they
believe
that globalization the internet will
eventually lead china to becoming a
democracy like us
he says it all the time open up the
social media bring in youtube bring in
uh instagram bring in facebook then we
can talk you've said that how many times
pat
yeah yeah many times but but here's
here's and we've talked about this
before here's my thing though
first of all let's go through priorities
okay so let's just say if i'm recruiting
you to work for the us government
what's above anything the country is
above
anything so if you're gonna go faith
family business let's just say god is
number one if the you know military you
swear oath you know
you're going to be president you put
your hand on the bible okay let's pay
faith but next is what
you got your family let's just say but
country
what are we doing like some of these
things do you know how many people i
know
who have are senior people in government
who have a family member that has either
worked or
is working in china how many
watts at a very high and we're talking
at a very high level of the government
they have you know a brother they have
some family member that is working in
china
so so i mean this
mcconnell's sister-in-law yeah
no no that's the dad no
his sister-in-law is on the board of the
bank of china
what about his wife mcconnell's wife
trump calls her right father but listen
what you say that one more time
sister-in-law sits on the bank
board of bank of china bank of china
sister-in-law
so but but here's let me let me go back
to my argument
of the last few years of why a guy like
trump was hated so much
okay go to presidents who didn't have a
need for money
what happened to those guys go to
presidents who are true believers
or didn't have a need for money where
you couldn't buy them
lincoln you couldn't buy him what
happened to lincoln we know how that
ended up mm-hmm
kennedy you couldn't buy him what
happened to him we know how that ended
up
reagan had his own money you couldn't
control him you couldn't buy him we know
how that almost ended up couple inches
away would have that ended up killed i
don't know almost
trump trump didn't need money he created
enemies we know how he ended up by the
way
he may have not gotten assassinated but
he got characters
there was another guy there was another
guy that that i actually voted for and
that's perrault
i really really was i was sad to see him
drop out and then i think he really
could have been
something oh i don't disagree i think he
he could have created a whole new
generation of people that would have
gone in
the middle we needed a third party at
the time he was the guy that got closest
to it
but but the part the part that scares
the
hell out of somebody when you when you
think about you're dealing with these
government guys
these are people that are making 100 150
000 a year what the hell is 150 000
nothing so you offer 150 000 this is why
who's easier to bribe college players or
nba players
college college i'll give you the number
though
i'll give you the number that i have the
the number that i heard going rate
uh stepping out of 150 000 a year job
was eight hundred thousand dollars a
year to do what to basically
speak on behalf of so we're gonna five x
your salary wait wait say this one more
time
eight hundred thousand dollars to do
what to basically
go back and interface to sell out how
does that money be transferred to you
how's that money paid to you through
some kind of
private entity so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye